- "The Office" had a huge comeback.
Like, the last several years,
I think as streaming, like everybody,
like all those shows that
maybe you were popular
years ago are coming back around.
Is that cool to like, have
a whole new fan base for it?
- It's totally insane and
mind blowing, honestly.
Like, there are kids who weren't even born
when the shows started,
who are now like avid fans and it's--
- Because it's a great show.
- [Ed] And it's a thrill.
Yeah. It's totally, totally amazing.
Randall was on "The Office".
- [Kelly] I know.
- I did an episode and it's crazy
because I did one--
- Is that what you meant?
I'm just kidding. (laughs)
- That's what I thought?
But apparently, it wasn't.
But I did
one
scene
in one episode.
I was in and out in like, a couple hours.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
That one scene is probably
the thing I'm recognized most for
(Kelly and Ed laugh)
to this day.
- That's how powerful you are. So..
- It makes our show "True
Story" and "The Office" reunion.
- [Randall] That's right.
- [Kelly] It does.
- Right?
- So in "The Office" you
did a lot of acapella.
And like I mentioned on "The Voice",
you came back and you were on "The Voice"
and I know you kicked
John out of your group,
but Blake is now a member
of your acapella group.
- [Ed] Yeah and Ariana.
The whole gang.
Everybody's in the group.
- [Kelly] Yes. Just not John.
- Except for John.
(Randall and Kelly laugh)
Yeah. John and I have,
we've been rivals for decades.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- [Randall] Decades.
- [Kelly] It makes sense--
- Since Beyoncé's party
and here we are. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Since Beyoncé's...
(Kelly wheezes)
- [Ed] But yeah, I've done--
- Since we had an acapella
at Beyoncé's party.
- Oh, that's right. Of course.
- [Kelly] Did you grow up though really,
like, singing acapella?
- Not acapella per se, but I was like,
kind of like, a chorale nerd.
- [Kelly] I was too!
- Yeah, okay. So like,
singing all the time.
My buddy Warren Goodrich and I sang
"More Than Words"
at a high school pep rally which
doesn't even sound cool. I
think we thought it was cool
to do that, but it--
- I still think it's cool,
which is why I was the nerd.
- And I'm still proud of it.
(Kelly wheezes)
But I think,
I think that technically it was not cool.
And that's part of what makes me not cool
is that I don't agree with that.
I still think it's cool.
- [Kelly] I still think it's cool.